[Music]
foreign
did you know that there are 10 giant sea
monsters that are from the mech
franchise which means that these sea
creatures here in this list are both
from the mech novels in which there are
seven of them and also from the two
movies aside from the Titanoboa the
T-Rex which are terrestrial as well as
the small aquatic dinosaurs there are 10
creatures along with the Megalodon that
are featured in the overall franchise
and these are gigantic so let's get to
them
okay firstly the Megalodons well let's
start with the big M's these are the
sharp species that are the heroes of the
books or anti-heroes or villains and
like all other creatures on this list
they avoided extinction by surviving in
the Deep Oceanic trenches in the
Marianas below the thermocline layer
whatever that is these sharks are
definitely bigger than the ones that
really existed millions of years ago
they are in the novel stated to be
around 70 to 80 feet in length while in
the movies they are clearly shown to be
over 30 meters or 100 feet whatever the
case may be they are no doubt the stall
both the shows and the books the main
Mech in the storyline is actually a
specimen called Angel and she herself
has had pups of her own as well as
siblings the other sharks which are also
notable are called Bell Scarface Lizzy
and Angelica
number two the Kraken so in the latest
movie The Meg 2 the trench there were
other monsters Beyond just the Sharks
among them was a particularly shadowy
creepy and fear-inducing cephalopod bees
which we call the Kraken this creature
wasn't anywhere in the books but it was
a unique entry from the movie
adaptations this could also 100 feet
creature boasted striking yellowish eyes
with Slender pupils reminiscent of an
octopus's gaze its ball was head and
dark gray black Hue coloration added to
its imposing presence while its long
tentacles are done with suction cups
completed its menacing appearance
number three the giant Square so in the
first movie there was another cephalopod
creature unrelated to the Kraken seen in
the sequel this animal was a giant squid
and it also resided in the trench it was
red in color and had numerous tentacles
as well as a long bulbous head as is
evident in other squid species when the
character in the movie called suyin
attempted a rescue mission the
submersible she was in was attacked by
this creature that could have been
anywhere between 9 to 12 meters or 30 to
40 feet long it was however developed by
one of the Sharks the Megalodons and
acid was a visible and easy prey item
due to the encounter with a submersible
number four the chronosaurus so in the
second Meg novel called the trench the
book introduced a chronosaurus a
prehistoric sea creature from the late
Cretaceous Period this Edition set the
tone for the mech franchise by expanding
the cause of ancient deep sea creatures
the chronosaurus here in the novel was
said to be a packed species and traveled
in groups thus being a threat even to
the Megs three of them appeared in a
secret novel and all three were killed
in various encounters differently one of
them was devoured by Angel the Meg these
Grand Sorrows were at least 12 meters or
40 feet long
number five the Leo pluradon this right
here is the main overarching enemy of
megalodons in the trench this is the
only creature which is definitely bigger
and longer than a Megalodon shark in the
novel hell's aquarium the leopyridon
serves as a primary enemy in the story
this creature resides in the battle last
sea dominating the area as the largest
inhabitant measuring 37 meters or 122
feet in length and weighing over 100
tons conflict arose when it clashed with
Angel the large albino Megalodon over a
prey that angel had called as Angel
becomes entangled and a fishing net
later on in the storyline the Lira
pluradon ultimately ends her life in
another novel that exactly leopleurodon
was killed but then an offspring of her
survived the mother's death and this
ensured the species survival into the
future therefore still having the
Rivalry with the Megalodons
[Music]
number six the Leviton malvale the
deadly whale which actually shared the
Seas with a Megalodon during the same
time millions of years ago the Leviathan
melvale became a recent addition to the
mix series making its first appearance
in the 2016 book Meg night stalkers the
name liviton meaning Leviathan has
become a common term in aquatic horror
and even inspired a title of a deep sea
horror movie this relative of the sperm
whale was said to have fought megalodons
back in the day these species had a
rivalry they both killed each other
whenever possible and these whales were
thought to be around 17 meters or 56
feet long
number seven the lock following the Meg
Steve atlin the author wrote another
book called the lock which applied a
similar approach to the Loch Ness
monster legend the book presents the
creature as an amphibious Predator
rather than a blister from millions of
years ago the two series eventually
intersect with the Loch Ness monster
creature appearing in the Meg Hills
aquarium the lock has its own sequel
called vostok which introduces
extraterrestrial elements into the
expanding Mech Universe this move
generated mixed reactions from fans but
a line the series existing Fantastical
elements the size however is unconfirmed
as of now
number 8 the Dunkleosteus another
extinct sea monster here rather a large
fish species that has also appeared in
the novel was the armored Dunkleosteus
and as it is called in the novel hell's
aquarium the monster fish this would be
one of the oldest species in the
franchise with its Heyday being 380 to
350 million years ago hundreds of
millions of years ago even before the
dinosaurs the biggest species of this
fish was estimated to be 9 to 10 meters
or 30 to 33 feet long this creature as
with all the others survive in the
battle last sea
number nine the helicoprion a strange
and yet similar creature to appear in
the same novel is the ancestor of the
Megalodon itself the helicoprion was
thought to have existed around 270
million years ago but like the dark
glasses they both defied death and
defeat for countless ages of the Earth
for them is the Lovecraft code that
holds true dark is not dead which can
Eternal lie and with strange eons even
death may die
this shark species has a very strange
spiral lower jaw with teeth arranged in
linear rows jutting out from the mouth
the shot was estimated to be around 11
to 12 meters or 36 to 40 feet long close
to the mag
and number 10 the mosasaurus and yes we
also have the mosasaurus here in this
list it appeared in the novel The Mech
Hills aquarium as well it was one of two
specimens that attacked the characters
of the story in the panther last sea one
of them was killed when a laboratory
fell on its head while the other one was
killed by Angel the Meg yeah here we
have a Mech going head to head with a
mosasaurus and the shark wins although
it was a short-lived Victory as Angel
got trapped in a net and was killed by
the larger leopleer Zone anyway these
mosasaurs weren't really given a size
estimate but real life studies and
forces indicated that they were around
17 meters or 56 feet long
anyway here in the novel we also have
the Titanoboa which is also one of the
biggest snakes in the world to ever
exist we also have the T-Rex which is
one of the biggest airports and also
smaller aquatic dinosaurs which we saw
in the movie which didn't really make
sense
anyway those are 10 giant sea monsters
from the mech books and movies and also
with a few notable mentions on the
terrestrial animals
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
and new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam
[Music]